[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okay mom
and I am filming this on my couch on a
weekday evening this evening I'm going
to answer your most asked questions
about pregnancy so what I did was post
on my Instagram it's right here if you
don't follow me if you think of a
question feel free to ask me and I
opened it up for questions from my
followers and I compiled the most
frequently asked questions and that's
what I'm going to be answering this
evening so for those who don't know I am
only six and a half months pregnant at
this point I've been pregnant several
times so I know why extensively the ins
and outs of pregnancy I'm not a doctor
but I feel like I am equipped to answer
a lot of these questions but number one
most asked question is what am I craving
well it has changed from child to child
this time around my craving is flamin
hot cheetos very spicy food I'm obsessed
with popsicles
oh and the Caesar salad um I cannot get
enough Caesar salad I love it so much in
terms of weird cravings this time around
I've been craving raw bread dough I
don't know what it is it's something
about the smell it just smells like it
would taste really good and I just I
want to take a bite how did you know you
were pregnant now this is a fun one to
answer but it's also not the most fun
answer for everybody out there I'd say I
just I had a feeling maybe it's just
intuition or hunch but with each of my
kids I knew I was pregnant before I took
the test somebody wanted to know if it's
normal to have swollen feet all the time
it
really varies from person to person I
get pretty swollen by the end of the day
while they talk a lot about swollen feet
and your feet growing during pregnancy
it's actually your whole body because
you have a lot more blood in your body
when you're pregnant
is it safe to color your hair during
pregnancy this is something that I
always instruct people to talk about
with their doctors what comments are
using who's doing it where are you
located are you in an enclosed room
there are so many factors that go into
the safety of coloring your hair that I
can't give a yes-or-no answer so that's
definitely a conversation to have with
your own doctor do you really poop
during labor
oh it varies from person to person I
don't think there's a concrete yes or no
to that and to be honest when you're
like trying to push your baby out that
is the last thing you're thinking how
have each of your pregnancies felt
different
they've all been very different actually
with Jackson he was an enormous baby and
so it was extremely uncomfortable it was
also my first in my body was adjusting
to being pregnant for the first time so
it was pretty painful and then with why
it was a little bit different I think
because my immune system was fairly low
being pregnant compromises your immune
system but I got sick a lot when I was
pregnant with Wyatt to the point that
I'd vomit so much I had to go to the ER
to stop contractions because the
vomiting was causing my body to start
having contractions and think that it
was time to go into labor so my
pregnancy was why it was a little bit
more tricky if that makes sense
but with Wyatt I was so emotional
his Tyrone I just feel a lot more
emotionally stable and a little more
clear-headed about everything maybe it's
maturity maybe it's this baby's pretty
chill I don't know
which trimester is the worst trimester
basically second trimester is the only
decent one while say that first
trimester is just you feel achy like one
permanent hangover third trimester is
the time that everything's getting big
nothing's fixed it's uncomfortable to
sleep
you're feeling the size of the baby in
other parts of your body like your lungs
and hips and your pelvis and your
muscles across your abdomen and so in my
opinion I'd say third trimester is
probably the worst what is the scariest
part of pregnancy
honestly all around pregnancy is pretty
scary there are so many aureus and
complications and things that can happen
to you and to the baby this time around
right now I am really scared of
delivering the baby not because of how I
will feel or how it can impact me but
recently I had a very unpleasant
experience having my miscarriage at the
hospital and it really caused me to lose
a lot of trust in hospitals and my
doctor and I think part of it is
probably irrational part of it is
probably just feeling trauma from what
happened but I can say right now that my
biggest fear is having to go to the
hospital I don't know I just I feel a
little bit lost right now but I have
some time there's time for me to get
better feel better about it what does it
feel like when the baby moves
can you feel which body parts are moving
can you feel where the baby is inside of
you and what exactly does it feel like
it's really hard to explain somebody
wrote please don't say it feels
alien inside of you but it kind of does
feel like an alien inside of you I think
the closest thing I can compare it to is
like big bubbles moving around in your
stomach like if you have a really really
big air bubble moving around like that's
kind of how it feels from the inside
sometimes I can tell what the body part
is like you can if it's bigger you kind
of tell it's like there but and if it's
more jazzy it's either like a hand or a
foot but it is hard to nail down where
exactly he's positioned and like what
body part is doing what it's more of
just a an overall like wool does your
skin hurt as your belly stretches I
wouldn't say it hurts anymore itches for
me I'm right here on the couch or making
a video what is the best and worst thing
about pregnancy so the best thing for me
this pregnancy is I work at BuzzFeed and
I work at tasty and everyone is so nice
to me when they wrap their shoots they
save me some of the leftovers and so I'm
constantly fed at work another thing I
love this time around being pregnant is
my kids are old enough to understand and
so they're very sweet and they like to
talk about Oh who's gonna teach the baby
how to read who's going to teach the
baby how to play soccer and then they
throw name suggestions and they're
really funny and they just they get a
lot of joy out of it and so that's been
really amazing to watch the worst part
of this pregnancy has got to be what's
called a round ligament pain which I do
not remember having with my other kids
but there's a ligament that stretches
across the base of your stomach and if
you are exercising or exerting yourself
or even coughing it really really hurts
like the shooting stabbing pain like
when it first happened to me I did not
know what was happening as I was dying
this is pregnancy painful yes it is
painful it's not very comfortable I
probably have a very different
perspective than somebody who loves
being pregnant do you want another baby
after this one no how do the kicks feel
I feel like a lot of people have this
perception of the kicks being like oh
but my kicks are like like he's just
banging on the walls are the doctor's
appointments invasive at the beginning
not really towards the end they will be
more and more invasive as they check to
see if you're dilating which is your
cervix opening in preparation for labor
so they will be like feeling and
checking for that and so it does get
invasive that's why it's really
important to be really comfortable with
whoever the OB may be are you allowed to
complain yes and loudly I mean I think
pregnant women have every right to
complain to vocalize any discomfort to
vocalize any unhappiness I think that is
the key to having a healthy pregnancy
and postpartum is to be open and honest
because it is not all rainbows and
butterflies and the more we try to
pretend that it is the more happy it can
make somebody and last but not least I
got asked this question at least a
hundred times does labour hurt is the
short answer is yes the long answer is I
think everybody has a very different
experience with labor even from my first
to my second child it was completely
different but one thing is for sure it
hurt like heck by far the worst pain
I've ever experienced and it's a very
strange it's very weird I only remember
it because I wrote
down I can't physically remember what
the pain felt like it is something that
anyone who has been through it should be
proud of because it is pretty metal
that's like out for today I'm Hannah and
if you have any more questions about
pregnancy leave them in the comments or
you can message me directly on the
Instagram and I might answer there or I
might see in the comments and answer
there and if I get enough maybe we'll
just make a whole other video about it
so next time
[Music]